The Joe Rogan Experience
the people that uh I'm quitting when the
special come out mom
do you want a um cigar no no last time I
did that [ __ ] it [ __ ] me up cigars
[ __ ] you up how so
it just made my [ __ ] all dry I mean this
ain't healthy but I'm an addict
definitely not health I'm just making
excuses how often do you smoke them
cigarettes yeah
God damn
I don't know probably
you know it's it's it changes when I'm
doing comedy or when I'm when I'm
performing you perform you smoke more
yeah interesting I smoke more when I'm
at the comedy store and [ __ ] because
everybody else is doing it it's social
no no one else does it no one very few
kind of [ __ ] like most people like
you know it's just the era of the
healthy comic ah those [ __ ]
they're judging you judges goddamn
judgey [ __ ] mom special comes out today
I'm done
that's it you're done I told her I told
her when it comes out I'm done and what
are you gonna do to replace it you're
gonna do gum you're gonna do the the
[ __ ] you put in your mouth she knows how
I was hanging out with Shob at Schultz's
wedding and he takes those little dip
pouches shoves him his mouth he grabbed
three of those [ __ ] and stuck
them inside his cheek like a squirrel
and I go what are you doing he goes I'm
an addict because I'm a straight addict
I can't do it man the [ __ ] so this so
one time when I was a when I was
deployed
we we had our little this was my second
appointment so by this time we had like
more Comforts and [ __ ] and we had our
little six a little 12 by six can or
whatever but my can so there's and
there's there's six Marines sleeping in
one of these things fun but my can had
we we had negotiated with the locals and
we had a TV we had an Xbox and we had a
little makeshift couch that we had built
and like made comfortable so everybody
would come in our room and like watch
The Sopranos or play uh coming out Canon
and all that [ __ ] and this one
[ __ ] I can't remember his name
anyway this son of a [ __ ] had this
weird habit of leaving his dip bottles
every [ __ ] way right oh no yeah and
one day and you know one day I'm sitting
there I'm drinking my [ __ ] and I put it
down by my feet and I reached back down
and I grab it not looking ah mouth full
of dip spit
it took three people to pull me off that
[ __ ] it wasn't fair to be mad at
him for real
people not paying attention but but I'm
I can it's you know you have those
events where you can't control yourself
you relive them like every time I think
about it I can taste it and I just I
could never dip I could never dip and I
I'm still mad about it
I've dipped it yeah it um it definitely
gives you a nice little head rush but
not as good as cigarettes cigarettes
give you the best head brush
yeah it's like whoa but um I love a
cigarette before I go on stage I don't
know how I'm gonna replace that
like right before I'm gonna try to use a
jewel or something like that I don't
know that doesn't work good enough no I
think you just have to stop like you
have to stop I started um
I had this book called the easy way to
stop smoking
and everybody that I've got to read the
book they've stopped and then but I've
never finished it
what does it tell you to do it's it's so
the premise of it is basically like they
instead of
telling you the reasons you shouldn't
smoke they attack the reasons why you
say you smoke like all the reasons
people give and they show you that
they're just excuses that you're just as
much of an addict as a crackhead or
that doesn't help you I think what helps
people is things like ibogaine ibogaine
um mushroom trips things like that yeah
but oh yeah I know a lot of people that
uh my buddy that um actually he just
left he moved down here actually
um Mitch
I can't remember Mitch's last name God
damn it
anyway he quit after a mushroom trip he
was like he did shrooms and was like no
I was just done yeah yeah well you start
thinking about what you could be doing
to your body you know what what could be
happening inside of your body yeah so
maybe maybe I just need a picture of a
tumor
you just hang over a health scare a
little bit of Health well I've had
enough of those that doesn't stop people
really no no cigarettes there's people
that's people that's dying in the
hospital now that's still sneaking out
to smoke cigarettes yeah but that's just
because they know they're dying I'd
rather just take the cigarette now other
than like die and not enjoy a cigarette
because you're already dying so you need
so you said the type of health care
where they like look stop you stop now
yeah you'll be okay but if you don't
stop now yeah maybe one of those
Something's Gonna like they're gonna
show you your lungs or you see the
Blackness like the tar and all the
[ __ ] Decay have you seen like a
smoker's lung when they pull it out and
they they put it next to a healthy
person's lung on an autopsy table yeah
and it looks it's wild it's yeah go see
if we can find a video they there or a
photo there's they do autopsies of these
people who die lung cancer and you know
lifetime cigarette smokers and they're
[ __ ] their their lungs
they look like they're just covered look
at that look at that [ __ ] lung look
at the like lung jerky look at that one
the the black lungs of a chain smoker
the one the upper left click on that
look at that that is insane man
that's so insane
that looks like someone oh my God look
at that next to a regular lung that is
so wild one lung is like uh orangey
reddish pink and the other one is
literally black and white like white
tissue and black tissue
[ __ ] wild man that is wild
terrible as I God damn it smoke myself
this is like that one up there that won
the second down right below that look at
that oh Jesus Christ look at they're all
shriveled this is like showing me stool
samples while I'm eating yeah but that's
if I'm still hungry I'll still eat
really you can just put power through it
I was on Fear Factor it's not real this
is a computer oh it's computer General
oh okay oh but still pretty accurate
probably accurate but the one next to it
is real that's real damn what's wrong
with that one down there the one that
looks like like it has cheese on it
which one's that the one in the middle
what is that
um
good God it's [ __ ] up because like the
thing that scares people the most is not
being able to breathe
you know that's what's interesting it's
like that feeling that you can't breathe
is terrifying to people that's why
drowning is so terrifying to people but
they say that the last days of a
person's life when they're dying of lung
cancer is like drowning it's like you
you can't breathe and you're you're
gasping for air and it's like your lungs
are filling up with fluid you can't get
any Oxygen in there because all the
sores are like popping
ugh as you tap and take another hit you
went through that cigarette quick too
oh how many did you smoke a day
oh it varies
but a packet the most yeah it's a lot
but it's a pack 16 how many is in there
20 20. it's actually perfectly
formulated for you to smoke all day oh
so if you start early and keep going
it's it's like the the rate that like
the nicotine gets out of your system
yeah and it's supposed to be like every
40 minutes or something like that and so
the sick you have just enough cigarettes
to smoke all day long you know what's
interesting like nicotine is actually a
medicine nicotine itself
um I think it's got heart applications
see like nicotine for heart nicotine and
so they use it to treat you nicotine by
itself is not bad which sounds so crazy
and it's also
um a nootropic meaning like uh it
stimulates cognitive function like
nicotine does stimulate it's one thing
Stephen King said in his book on writing
is that quitting cigarettes was very
hard for them because it's like his
writing suffered a little bit it's
harder for him to write
oh dude
because there's something about the
cigarette that like it fires up the
synapses it fires up the brain and then
the writing would come smoother
yeah I don't know I don't know because
I've I've smoked all the time I've been
doing comedy and writing so I mean that
would be that would be like torture like
if I couldn't if the ideas came to me
less yeah I think that's what what he
was saying but I think you can you could
probably get around that with other
stuff